all right so I guess we're ready so
we're gonna do this thing it's kind of
funny cuz there's not as many people
here as usual somebody came in they said
what are you doing I said part three
they're like all right I can't follow
the plot they're out so next week we'll
do something a little different we won't
do like a three-part series we'll just
do one opening or something I do want to
read one funny comment though that I got
on one of these videos Paul Smith who
said your title writer deserves a raise
so that's Ben Simon over there pumping
his fist he came up with a the title
this is the modern Benoni
is no baloney part three and John Boyer
disagrees with that statement so he's
not here watching this okay but we
continue and this is you know an opening
where the first week I guess we went
over the time on of attack with you know
II four and f4 and I attack you and try
to crush you immediately then we went
over the modern main line which you know
has efore and Knight f3 today we're
going to look at lines with where they
withhold efore for like a while I will
flip the board's look at it from blacks
point of view for some reason and we'll
continue so in this line we're actually
going to come to the position in a
slightly unusual way but the normal way
of reaching it I'm gonna have to go back
or the computer is going to get mad at
me the normal way of reaching this
position is by striking at the center
and we're looking at lines with a six
not B 5 so here we get the benoni and
tonight in this position that we've seen
several times now we're going to look at
the move Knight to f3 and you know not
playing efore immediately but I'm gonna
go back just for a second because
otherwise just bass gets mad at me we'll
reach the same position via a slightly
different move order ok so this is where
we start today and when you you don't
play e4 immediately White's
either going to have a plan with the
fianchetto which will be what we're
going to look mostly at today and we're
also going to have a look at the
right store where the night makes an
immediate jump all the way over to see
for often in conjunction with Bishop 2f
for attacking d6 and trying to cause
black some annoyances right from the
start
alright so first of all we'll go over
the main move so we realize that this
Bishop belongs on the long diagonal here
and we're going to focus mostly on g3
but let's go ahead and let's have a look
at the knight store and we've seen this
maneuver before where the knight goes to
c4 that's very typical in these lines so
you might be wondering what if they just
do it right away and if you know you're
new to this opening perhaps it's unusual
you move your knight three times rate it
right at the beginning but it's you know
a very sophisticated opening where such
maneuvers are definitely possible and
we'll look at how black should handle
this okay we weren't going to fianchetto
and we're going to look mostly at night
to c4 but it is worth mentioning this
apply e4 they've started of transposed
to some of the main lines that we've
already looked at you know they've
before we did a couple move orders but
basically you know you can castle and
just get sort of a normal position and
we're going to see black does his
typical maneuvers he puts all of his
pieces here you know he's trying to play
b5 he's trying to take control over a 5
so that white doesn't play e5 he's
trying to put this move on the board
so we'll see these typical maneuvers and
okay if if here you get sort of a normal
position if here you get sort of this
typical sort of structure where White's
trying to play for a 5 flex can
eventually try to play b5 on get Queen
side play but since the focus of the
lecture is a on what happens when they
withhold e4 we'll take a look at the
Knights tour okay so we Castle and they
attack our D pawn for a second time
and the main move here is to protect
your pond which is generally a good idea
but we will come back to this position
and we'll look at some crazy ways that
you can try to sacrifice your D pond and
the Darien will sit there and shake his
head yeah it'll be great so okay this is
the main move and it's worth just seeing
what the main plan is for both sides so
Queen d2 which actually is a interesting
move now sometimes in these types of
positions and we'll see a little bit of
this black is thinking about playing the
crazy-looking g5 and you know if you go
back here I come and I'm going to go
trap you so this sort of crazy g5 stuff
is going to happen a lot in this lecture
because we've seen a little bit but
we'll see it a little bit more tonight
that is a typical idea that black does
have so Queen d2 you know prevents g5
gets control of some more dark squares
okay now b6 is the main move though
there's also this interesting version
that Korchnoi played which looks very
strange you get rid of your bishop but
as we've kind of seen in the Benoni
you often give away your dark squared
bishop for a knight and it's strange
because if you play the dragon or you
play the Gruden fold you never want to
like give up that bishop it's the
greatest piece ever but in the benoni
very often you do just give it up so of
course when I played this and you want a
very complicated game though you know we
could equally look at and be equally
instructive but the main move here is b6
and after e3 and also interesting to
note too in these positions white has to
be careful with his epon you know a lot
of times
efore seems to be like you know isn't
that what you want to play don't wanna
play e4 but you do have to make sure
that if black plays f5 that he's not
getting a lot of counter play so if you
play e4 they can play f5 and if you're
not ready to play e5 yourself then very
often black and get counter play either
because you have to take or they can
take on the e4 so white always wants to
be really careful so in this version
okay just get the modest center we're
going to follow up Castle and then we're
going to take more action in the center
and as we've seen before this Bishop a6
move
which doesn't end to just take the night
because the night is such a strong piece
and the bishop on c8 often doesn't have
a really good job so after a move like a
four also black was hinting that perhaps
he was going to be able to play b5 which
is always what he wants to do on the
Queen side so a four prevents that and
f5 is a very reasonable move here it
prevents the knight from going to e4 but
the main move is just to take and you
get a position like this so we'll just
go a few more moves in reach this
position with typical play so why it's
eventually going to try to arrange for
all the standard stuff that we've we've
seen the blacks trying to go on the
Queen side but I do want to return to
this position and have a little bit of
fun because it's funny the computer move
is a movie like nobody plays so here so
I had a little bit of fun looking at
that but I will look at a move that
other humans have played which is this
sort of crazy looking move Knight to a6
just ignoring that the D pawn is
attacked twice and obviously if black
can play like this or if you can put is
Knight here and neither of the captures
work on d6 then you should probably play
this way so what a little fun we'll see
what happens the best move here is
probably e3 so we'll come back to this
but let's let's take how do you guys
want to take first with a bishop or a
knight nobody knows
all right nobody knows so I'll take with
the bishop first all right we take with
the bishop because it it's shorter then
we'll get to have a lot more fun taking
with the knight all right you attacked
my rook you want upon all very good so I
play rook e8 and the move that
everybody's played in this position is
Bishop g3 and whites like yes
you know robbed upon got away with the
crime I fled the scene but now white
actually gets I'm sorry black gets a
really good position after just the
simple move Knight to b4
and either you're getting this pawn back
with one of your pieces or you're
playing this move which would let your
knight go here and lead to you know very
powerful position so the computer wants
you just to play e3 and give the pawn
back so nothing special
and perhaps black is even a little bit
better in such a line so we'll go back
here and we'll have a little bit more
fun with the knight takes this is much
more interesting and what's kind of cool
about this is black actually can make
several forcing aggressive moves to
really keep the initiative and achieve
an advantage and the first move you can
pause your videos at home every move
here if you want to try to figure it out
for yourself is just this simple looking
move Knight to h5 a very common square
for the knight in these variations and I
simply intend to take your Bishop and
then you you know remove the defender of
your knight and it is worth noting
what's kind of funny if they take here
which is a mistake you just take the
bishop in the Knights trapped so that's
kind of funny are you amused okay good
Queen d2 is much better because it's
okay if you take the bishop I'm gonna
take back on my queen my Knights still
protected okay I go here
what's the threat now
mm-hmm yeah a knight takes Bishop and
when the Queen takes back you can go to
c2 so that's the threat so let's say we
protect that I seem sensible now I can
just take this and in such a position I
can even play here now what's the threat
yeah so we're threatening here we're
also threatening here we got a lot of
threats this time so okay now you can
take attacking the Queen take the knight
okay and you get a position like this
where yeah you're still up a pond I can
always you know win it back and then I
can take this guy
so I mean black it really has a serious
initiative here just for for a little
pond and yeah we do have this threat
still in the position so this actually
would be a lot of fun for black who has
yeah these at least getting his pawn
back but he's just much better developed
and white still has to prove that he can
castle in this position so okay all in
all a lot of fun for for black so we'll
return to this position after Knight a6
and again if they can't take on d6 then
you should play this way but if III now
we can go back and we'll get a similar
version as the main line only the
difference is instead of Queen d2
they've played III and we'll see why
this makes a difference because it's
such a variation you can play sort of
the aggressive plan mentioned earlier g5
with the idea f5 and you're threatening
to win the bishop so why would have to
play something you know like f4 and you
can either play g4 or you can just play
like Knight one of your Knights to c7
you know you could just go back and okay
it's a sort of dynamic play that black
is playing for when you play the benoni
this is sort of the crazy position that
you want and I don't know I assume it's
it's equal but it's very dynamic so
there's a lot of chances to play for a
win for both sides in such a crazy
position
but yes okay so that's the night tour
variation that's what happens when they
you know immediately go to see four with
the night but now that's let's focus
here on the fianchetto variation which
is actually very theoretical so it is
you know it's quite difficult if you
don't know what you're doing and I used
to play this way all the time with white
and I really liked it
in everybody every time I'd play it and
I had great success with it it's just
one of those openings where I just had
good success so I kept doing it
everybody would always say after the
games like in the post mortem
you know this is terrible you shouldn't
play this way white that's no way to get
an advantage which is probably true but
I kept winning so I kept playing it and
I beat some relatively high rated
players with this as white and I think
it's just because both sides need to
know a lot of theory but now Boris
avrech wrote a book about this position
as white so now everybody thinks is cool
so now I don't play it I only play it
when they don't think it's cool okay
we're just going to develop our bishops
in this both castle so here we get sort
of the starting position and for black
there's two main moves here they almost
always lead to the same thing the main
move is rook e8 which i think is more
accurate than a six
just because you are thinking sometimes
about playing this immediate Knight to
e4 which can often lead at least to
equality but a six is likely to
transpose to what we're about to see so
we'll go through it real quick after a
six white almost automatically plays a
for preventing b5 and now after the
normal moves right white goes on with
his normal plan black goes on with his
normal plan which are to play all of
these moves you'll get a position that's
that's very similar to what we're going
to see h3 is sort of an important move
it's sort of like in the Banco gambit
which is a cousin of the benoni that
we're looking at now black very often
has this idea in mind of rerouting the
Knight to e5
so h3 a good little waiting move and
we're going to see positions much like
this as we go along here so we'll return
to the main move
sorry in this position let's just focus
here on on rook to e8 and we're just
going to look at three moves in this
position so we'll watch three different
games the first game we're going to look
at the move up to e1 just putting the
rope behind the e pawn and then you'll
play e4 we'll also look at the second
most common move in a move I've seen
before I've been on both sides of this
so we'll look at at this move which
makes a lot of sense just targeting the
D pawn and we'll look at the main move
which is Knight - D - just maneuvering
the Knight to c4 okay in this first game
with rook to e1 was played in the u.s.
championship so I always love to show
games that were played here this is the
game between Kaden trough who was 16 at
the time he's at the club occasionally
throughout the year so very nice guy and
he's playing Hikaru Nakamura who became
the US Champion that year so I wonder
who won and okay it was a very
interesting game so rook e1 not very
common but I do just kind of like how
black played in this game and you get
sort of typical ideas that are worth
looking at okay he played a six right
very typical and so obviously a four he
goes here okay he's just doing all the
usual stuff and Kaden pushed and so now
we were sort of entering the middle game
planning where black has to start
thinking about what he's going to do so
maybe he just played sort of the natural
moves you got to this position but now
what do you do as black and as we kind
of mentioned similar to the Bangko
gambit
he went to g4 so we will see this
maneuver where the night maneuvers back
to e5 okay he's he sees that and he goes
here revealing an attack on the night so
the knight moves and the first thing you
might think when you see this position
as well as he just blundered I mean
don't you just play at four here well no
because then I just jump in to d3 which
often happens and you know I've seen
like Benko gambit games have just gone
terribly wrong when black gets this pawn
on c4 and one Knight goes in here and
the other night goes here and you just
get crushed on the like squares
immediately so these sorts of things are
in the position but right now it has to
worry about d3 so okay he plays this
move and now I'm threatening f4 so okay
I guess there's more than one move you
can play here there's there's lots of
things you can actually do but facing
the threat of f4 I guess how would you
guys react to this position what would
you guys play yeah g5 that's what he
played now obviously this weakens a lot
of like squares for example if a knight
could land on f5 white would be really
happy you know the Queen might go to h5
which would be very good but with your
Bishop on f1 you have made it sort of
difficult for this guy to travel to f5
also this guy has a another tricky
journey because you know he has to use
where the Queen's on so you have a
little bit of time before White's ever
able to get a Knight to f5 but if under
normal circumstances one of these nights
just blanc right there then you might be
in trouble
so we'll see can you get away with such
a move and typically these are the
dynamic moves that you're looking for
when you play this opening okay so Kanan
played h3 just controlling g4 Queen f6
so yeah I would like you to move this
night away and then I'll go here check
okay
and white went in here which I think
Caden after the game said he didn't
really like but I don't know it's okay
it's a good move because well his queen
actually end up getting trapped there
can black rearranges pieces and this is
sort of interesting one point of it too
you get your queen to a nice aggressive
square now the night is going to go to
that five so here's an interesting
planning exercise and you may want to
pause your video and again there's
multiple right moves here there's not
like one right plan or anything
but his plan that that Nakamura came up
with was is really interesting so I
think we should just spend a little bit
of time here just thinking about this
position and I just wonder what you guys
would play I like the one guy in the
audience is like oh and everybody else
is like I was too hard looking at the
floor in the game he chose the very
interesting move Bishop to h6 and his
idea is whenever the knight gets here or
sorry when the night goes to here he's
going to be ready and just take it so
we'll see again in the Benoni you give
away your dark squared bishop for a
night and you weekend all the dark
squares and then it's dynamic and crazy
three months after this game ding lauren
had this position and is black he played
the move h6 so I assumed this was an
attempt at an improvement I don't know
that it's really any better than when
Nakamura played but his treatment of
this position was very similar to yours
he got the knight out of the way just so
that if the knight ever goes here we can
grab it so this you know equally valid
but more unusual and entertaining is
Bishop to h6 okay so here goes the night
next we're going to e3 so g4
and if the night goes to III which it
did he intended to take it and okay so
will you get enough counterplay I mean
you did give away a dark square Bishop
and you've removed some pawns in front
of your King but if you just look at the
coordination of the white pieces you
know you realize you know are you good
out here or are you going to get trapped
you know how are you going to develop
some of these pieces even this guy I
don't think any of his pieces really
look truly brilliant in this position so
I mean what's going on and sometimes
when you're a kid even when you're a
grandmaster you play Nakamura all your
pieces are kind of all over the place
that just happens he went here which has
a big threat and the Queen will be
trapped for example Danny what what bad
move can I play here is white can't play
Bishop g2 and then h4 well you wanna
play h4 and then get trapped but then
you don't have the h4 and some lines
okay
a5 okay that's a good bad move I like
your bed moves better okay so here the
Queen is getting trapped so we go here
but h4 you you're trying to trap her
even earlier if I wanted to go to that
square yes and okay after here you can
go aha yup you haven't got me yet whoops
and okay now where are you going so the
there is a threat here the Queen is
getting trapped so let's not play that
move okay so he took right very good now
the Queen can escape and here Nakamura
play to move that he didn't really like
after the game because it's not the most
accurate move he took on g4 so we'll
come back but stronger is first playing
this move Knight to f6 and so sort of
the point is after your clean retreats
and it's kind of funny you have to go to
like h1 or something we can take here
and after some rook move we get a lot of
counter play with the move f5
and they're still you know some game is
probably balanced but it's a dynamic
sharp equality that is really difficult
to play and black is trying to get as
much counter play as possible to justify
having an attack because he gave away
you know lots of lots of squares and
whites going to play sort of a lot of
defense in this variation and if you can
consolidate he's got the more solid pawn
structure and safer King but okay takes
and now Kaden one here which is wrong b3
is a better Square but also very
important would have been this move so
this after this white should be a little
bit better and the point is we're
protecting f2 and why is that important
I don't know we'll find out so we'll see
why protecting up to was sort of
necessary but in the game this is where
he decided to go now if you attack the
Queen went all the way back to h1 okay
so he didn't come to pieces all right we
got to stay active you know maybe I can
get all my pieces over here and go do
stuff you know maybe I can do something
you know I can just bring my Brooke over
game another tempo on the Queen
maybe this Queen is going here maybe I
get some pressure here okay Lex got to
be active Queen f3 and Nakamura went
here and then the press-conference he's
like I'm a [ __ ] why did I play that
move but okay it's fine it's nothing
wrong with it I guess he was worried
about this move but I mean black and
just like continued developing sort of
like he did in the game and be fine you
can give up the b-pawn he does have an
attack and we'll see it but in the game
Caden went Queen to d3 so he's doing a
lot of Queen's moves and this was one
Queen move too many this is actually the
losing move so okay I questioned the
audience some Ian how are you going to
continue the attack here see if we can
you can play sharp chest like Nakamura
here the first move isn't the hard move
to find Queen h6 okay very serious
threat
that's where I just check me so okay he
defended in yeah if your rook you want
to have your queen here instead of your
rook because then you can go to h2 in
this check so how would you guys
continue now in the game he didn't do
that he went in with the check okay now
now that more difficult to find and he
played this like immediately you know he
starts like sacking all of his stuff and
but he's like I just did it immediately
to see to do you mean here you're
correct Wow very good alright so here
what was the point of this this night
sack well now we get this this big
Bishop move again with a big dread okay
it's starting to come together
okay Queen goes back and okay there's a
brilliant move here so continue and okay
I think somebody mentioned here but now
white is actually winning if he plays
like a computer for 20 more moves so
we'll show this variation just for a
laugh and then we'll go on and we'll
find the actual right move that was
played in the game you're just king f3
no big deal darienne's king you're on
it's on f3 every game we've ever played
or never okay and you can take and you
don't want to want red Queens you're
done some some material but you have
this move Queen h5 and it looks really
scary because you have some discovery
maybe my King can barely move out of the
discovery but it's no big deal you got
nothing and you really don't have a good
discovery and you okay if you go here
with the point that if you take you lose
your queen
okay I just play here no big deal you
got nothing you have no good discoveries
for example you can just play here and
then if we trade Queens then things are
good for me let me go here okay no big
deal and then we trade the Queens and
white will win so that's with perfect
play it's actually white that would be
able to turn the tables on black but I
don't know how much of that you
calculated because he's played instantly
which makes me think he just saw the
right move here and the incredible move
that was played in the game
rook take g4 very powerful move takes
takes King has to move not King f3
because you can even play here this is
very strong for black so he went to e3
and these you know a little bit of
danger took here just you know K and
then the game wrapped up pretty shortly
he picks up some more material check and
you can go to h8 we can repeat a little
bit we can go back and forth but he
decided to win which was a good idea I
guess and after here here the King had
to walk back and after this he has to go
to f1 and then it's main one so he
resigned in this position instead of
getting checkmated so you know a very
powerful example by black nakamura is
always you know 2 in a fighting mood and
this is sort of the trouble you have
when you're the higher rated opponent
you know even when you're in the u.s.
championship and you're playing
grandmasters you know 2500 s but you're
27 2800 you know you have to play stuff
like the benoni so it's a great opening
if you end up playing lots of lower
rated opponents because it's sharp and
imbalanced and you can play for a win
even with black even if you're playing
grandmasters so ok excellent powerful
attacking chess by nakamura and we'll go
ahead and I'll have to look at another
game here
all right this game is a little bit
shorter this is the game between
vasilyev on Chuck
and a niche theory but this was a rapid
game so it's game in 45 aka Lulu's
favorite time control I just played a
game with a reina game with Lulu
yesterday so expect to see that on one
of these Saturdays pretty soon it was
game in 45 that's what she likes so okay
then okay let's get to the position here
in this position it's actually reached
via Catalan opening okay so we we get to
our position in a slightly unusual way
and we have again the fianchetto
variation with the move rook to e8 okay
we're going to look at the second most
popular move here which is Bishop to f4
and it's move I again I find this as
both sides so it's very interesting and
there's a lot of ideas for black here
there's actually a lot of room to to be
creative in the game night to a6 so
again we see this Knight to a6 idea you
know we're either going to be four or
you're going to see seven the main move
is a six and okay automatically a four
and you can attack the bishop it moves
away you can get something like this
this is typical where you know again I'm
trying to play on the Queen side he's
going to start pushing in the center you
get sort of typical play for this
variation but again also possible after
Bishop to f4 is this idea of trading
Knights which often implies that you're
going to sacrifice an exchange because
when they take here you know they
normally will go back they're attacking
the rook in a couple different ways and
okay and black is seriously thinking
about taking the bishop now taking the
bishop immediately is the main line I
was playing a blitz game in one of the
Saturday night blitzes against opponent
rated about 2,400 and in this position
he played the move rook to b4 which I
actually didn't know at the time so I
was happy when I looked at
later that I played the right move a
three yeah I didn't know you know it's a
five-minute game I didn't really know
but I played it correctly and he took
and now after he takes here I can put my
Brooke on 82 and he went back and I was
actually much better for like the whole
game and then I you know I blundered
into a drawn position in time trouble
but a very you know interesting way to
play but more common in this position is
just to take immediately and okay you
reach sort of a similar position so this
type of play is also very interesting
you can consider this as black and it's
often why you know some people they
avoid this move order normally they
don't put their Bishop on f4 so early
normally they want it they want to
prefer in this position the main move
which we'll look at that prevents Knight
to e4 okay but we go on so this is
Yvonne Chuck for scary in that game
night to a6 all right all right
rook to e1 you put your rook there you
play e4 very good
all right Bishop to g4 and as in some
other variations often we put their
Bishop there and then we take the knight
so after h3 which is the normal move
most people take the knight but that
that's not what happened to this game
the bishop went back but most people
take their because they weren't bluffing
yeah as my comer would say I wasn't
bluffing I really wanted to take your
knight so the main line in this
variation actually goes you take you go
back which is also an interesting move
if you didn't have this it would be a
lot harder to play the black position
you know do you want that pawn
most people don't if you if you do take
it black has a really good move here
Queen to b6 attacking the bishop
attacking the beep on so after you go
back and this is a playable variation
white is going to give up an exchange so
here I'm just attacking your knight and
when it moves I am just winning an
exchange here and this position is
playable I mean there's so many lines
where both sides can give up exchanges
in this variation and
maintaining quality so I mean why would
have the two bishops and a decent game
but more common in such a position is
efore and you know just you know I
didn't want to win your pawn and the
knight can go to e5 and black and try to
get some Queen side play as per usual
our audience almost got a lot higher
rated almost but in the game he was
bluffing
he went to f5 it was all a joke and now
after this move again black played a
type of move that you want to look for
in these these sorts of positions you
know obviously you're attacking my be
pawn like play rip be a defend my pawn
but a typical sacrifice we've seen it a
few times now b5 okay and so why
basically has to accept and the point
was rook to b8 and even at the cost of
upon I start to get some initiative on
the Queen side which is exactly where I
want to play so when the Queen got out
of the pin attacks the knight on a six
black one here Queen d7 and you can
easily take on a six that should you
know be roughly equal he went back okay
you trade Queens with me and after you
trade now I'm protecting my be pawn and
I'm up upon array but now he get this
guy and it's going to get really
complicated and a mistake is about to be
made you know in a few more moves so
black takes here this is correct you
were attacking my rook I move my rook
and now a mistake though playing the
right move here is really hard it's
really hard in the game he took here
which is already losing though it looks
like the most natural move you could
possibly play and this is one is really
tough so I know will give you a chance
to pause your videos at home but I think
all
give it away the saving move that White
has in this position is is not rook D
1.e4 oh yeah of course
ah far followed by all sorts of
complicated training so after some
trades you know in in some fashion no
matter how you take stuff we should end
up trading all sorts of stuff and you
know again I can take here we can just
keep trading we can keep trading draw so
yeah II for was the move you had to find
not easy to find with any amount of time
on your your clock so congrats if you
found that at home but Bishop to c5
which is actually a huge blunder so this
is a move you guys a tactic you guys
might be able to solve so at home you
might want to pause your video in the
classroom I'll give the audience a
chance
what is the winning move here for black
this is the guy we want to attack
because we're trying to take this but we
need to get rid of the knight first so
it is definitely the right idea
Bishop c2 not quite correct because here
I did have a look at this you can play
here and even if you give up the
exchange the computer actually says is
dead equal and we're discussing before
the class started positions were you
down in exchange and is equal so I know
what side Darien would want to be on you
would like to have the exchange whereas
if it and we were talking about this and
if a position is like dead equal and I'd
like to be down in exchange because
normally that means it's a lot easier to
play your position and you have a lot
more practical chances so I mean I don't
really mind being either color here I
like white at two one one on the Queen
side look at all how many bishops I have
and I don't mind being white here
I'm going to take the bishop oh and then
we'll turn on this week computer fritz
actually likes black if it's pretty
likes black in this position there it
take okay so this actually is decent for
black but after this and even cleaner
way to win is putting attacking the
knight from the other square going to d7
okay and now it's already lost and the
game ended he took this and he took this
and he played like a few more moves and
they traded stuff and then he resigned
which is a bit strange but you know
you're down a piece so you give up now
if this was a kid's camp like they would
still resign and I'd be like why do you
resigned
but okay you're playing at the top level
I guess you can resign here yeah it's
three pawns to our plays yes I expect
even at this level and it's still a
rapid game there's a lot of time to
change things around but let's see what
for Fritz's evaluation we used Fritz for
some reason it's it's almost - - one
last game and we'll go over the main
main main super theoretical fianchetto
variation with lots and lots of theory
again in a rapid game so this is the
game between Krishnan SAS akhirin and
Vishwanath Anand again it was a rapid
game and here we get back to our
position again the Catalan I notice - I
would play the Catalan for a long time
as white and I think people would play
this move order a lot like they weren't
gonna play the benoni but when you play
the Catalan they like to go into it
thinking they've you know sort of
tricked you into an inferior version of
the benoni but Emily are that's why I
was going to play anyway so it never
bothered me but ok we get back to our
main position here which dealt with
castled in this game a 6 ok so we're
going to transpose to a line where you
play rook e8
a for automatic rookie eight and we're
going to look at the main move which is
Knight to d2 which again prevents black
from playing Knight d4 himself and this
is the main main line for the fianchetto
variation okay we develop our Knight to
the normal square and if you go to c4
right away which is like okay I guess
what will happen is black intended to
play Knight to e5 so this didn't happen
in the game we'll go back to the the
main line so we return to this variation
and here white makes sort of a useful
waiting move so we kind of looked at 90
you Knight to c4 Knight to e5 which is
perfectly fine for black but here the
move h3 just playing a little waiting
game so you know you don't have time to
go here because I just play a forward
and kick you back so black has to play
some useful waiting move rook b8 you
know this the most useful move you can
make so after the night goes here again
we challenged the night and we don't
want to trade so we go back to a3 and it
looks you know sort of terrifying maybe
your your Knights going to get stuck you
know just complain for kick you around
you have this move that we similar to
the other line with Knight to h5 and the
idea is if you play f4 and this is is
the game now but f4 was not played eeek
see they open the door for one second
like bugs are in here it's it's like
it's terrible out there I both doors are
open okay
but you can play this way you know
sacrificing a piece you get two pawns
but your attack here is actually quite
strong now the main move that's been
played at least by humans Knight to c4 I
could probably improve a bit on theory
here you can actually play this move
what's the point of this why are we why
are we doing this well here you have a
fantastic
tactic the audience perked up like Oh
fantastic tactic yeah that's what
they're here to see so you know I was
just saying I was you're gonna take your
Bishop so you get rid of it now you have
a little tactic here so you can pause at
home
alright so congrats to anybody they
found the move Bishop takes h3 and we do
have this idea looming in the position
so if they take you can play here and
you actually have too many threats
you're threatening to take the bishop
you're threatening to take here which
forces you to give up your queen or get
checkmated so this actually is already
winning for black just okay I mean so
again yeah Congrats have you found that
because it's not easy at all to find but
these are the sorts of tactics that
you're sort of looking for when you play
this variation and this is the the
saving tactic that in this position
prevents white from playing the move f4
and we're playing a little bit dangerous
with with some of our Knights as black
you know we're living on the edge we
have to know some theory because we're
counting on all sorts of little Knight
tricks to survive the opening here
efore this is the game now the main move
very good black goes here again if f4 we
can take on g3 and we're getting ready
to play b5 so a very interesting move is
possible here for white and was played
in the game and this is the main line a5
offering a pawn to get your queen out of
the way to prevent certain tricks and
we'll look at this so this is happen to
the game and then g4 and f4 and so we'll
see what happens and why it's important
for the Queen to be distracted if you
just play g4 immediately there's
actually a couple of different moves
here Queen h4 is a very interesting
sacrifice you can just give up Queen and
you're you still have a decent position
but more common is b5 alright if you
take my night I played before and I fork
your Knights
so they take they take again and even in
such a position it's actually black that
is better so okay you know I have these
ideas I might play here I might play
here and white has a whole bunch of
weaknesses so you've nothing to complain
about here as black and I don't know
both of your minor pieces are probably
better than whites so this actually
would be good for black but we'll see a
difference so in the game a five was
played and now the Queen is going to be
lured to the Queen side and the critical
test I mean is accepting the gambit and
you'll notice now that for a while
you're not going to be threatening this
because I well on some lines I get my
Bishop out well we'll look at them when
we get there you'll be able to take with
the knight so black has to be careful
but here he comes
okay we have to retreat here and you're
stuck the night is just trapped out
there so you have to sacrifice this was
the point so takes takes three pawns for
a piece
in the main move here f5 breaking the
connection of the bishop threatening to
take the knight then Danny and I can
discuss for hours what the best move is
here because that's what that's what we
talked about in preparation for this
lecture because there's two moves they
both make a lot of sense the most
popular and it's you know move 20 we're
still in theory is the move h5 which was
played by Anand but also Knight to e5
and I think this is also pretty good for
black I think I prefer black and most of
these positions and just to give you a
sample line f6 what do you do want to
play in this position you can and this
actually ISM this is the third most
common move so this move is okay too I
think I saw like the computer wants to
do but no humans do it even those that
are obviously prepared by command so
another thing I there's nothing wrong
with this move it's a move there's a lot
of moves in this position so move 20
there's still like lots of theory you
got to note so yeah that is that is
playable but 95 and to get this giving
an example and also it's funny is like
the computer always plays different than
the humans would in this position
because they're sort of long-term things
going on now like every human always
goes back to h8 and like all of these
positions but you know the computer
I guess doesn't see that the long-term
weakness of f6 means you won't be
trapped forever so the computer always
wants to go here but you know that's not
what anyway that's ok so I mean yeah the
computer also like wants to do stuff
that it's not truly correct because even
though we're in move 20 people spend
lots and lots of hours so I guess in
such positions I'd always trust what you
know the world champion with maximum
preparation is choosing over what the
computer said especially when the
evaluation is so minimal but to give you
an example of what the main line after
Knight d5 is a position like this where
he tries to hold on to f6 even though
you have three pounds for a piece you
know one of them is trapped
h8 you know how are you what you can do
about that and you know we can go back
we get you know some position like this
and we'll be sort of similar to the game
but in the mainline here
h5 if I just want to keep my night there
seems like a good square for a night
move Bishop g5 you couldn't play h6
because I kept my knight there so now
you're gonna play h6 sorry sorry f6 here
now that you know there are some ideas
that okay now we can't play here you'll
notice because rook would embarrass our
queen so queen bee for just gets out of
any possible threats and maybe I'll take
on b2 maybe I'll come back into the game
a different way and you'll see what what
the Queen ends up doing is kind of
interesting so I have six and he was a
human so you went back to h8 will he be
able to win that powers the bishop
trapped for the rest of the game that's
that's a big question in the middle game
okay
and now we've seen before this idea
where the bishop goes here and a lot of
lines check he does something similar
only this time it's a queen so that's
that's interesting so he was keeping the
d4 square available for his Queen Jack
I'm you know metric Queen's and then I
can win on f6 so you take I take you go
back and you might go get my pawn now
another you know sort of dynamic move
well here I actually can just win a
temple on the bishop
and here this is going into move 26 here
was about to place 26 move a theoretical
novelty so obviously you know very very
theoretical this opening yeah his move
was Bishop to h4 which hadn't been
played before and hasn't been played
sense because it's not a very good move
the main move is Bishop to f4 and you
get an equal position after taking this
taking this you know going back and will
lose your stuff and this should be equal
if you ever put anything on e5 if you'll
get trade lots of stuff and you should
be equal which is why that's the main
line but okay I mean how do you prove
that this is such a bad move well
weakness of the last move the bishop no
longer is on this diagonal loop so here
goes the night all right is he going to
move his rook no I just take this in an
interesting decision I guess what would
you guys in the audience play I know
we're running a little bit low on time
but yeah he took the bishop which is
which is excellent yeah taking you know
the exchange is not as valuable because
you're probably gonna have to end up
giving it back so he ends up taking the
bishop and the idea is now you win the e
pawn and you know you for cam so he only
has one move so he saved both of his
pieces with Knight to f3 but now this
next move which is excellent is the
reason why you shouldn't play put your
Bishop on on h4 it's not obvious to see
how black can really exploit this but
Bishop f5 and we're low on time so I'll
just explain the idea the idea is we go
here check and we put the Bishop on e4
and we're threatening to take the knight
and win the bishop and if the bishop
moves anywhere off this diagonal like
sage III because when I checked you you
can probably want to have to you know
well then you're get dropping this guy
so that's the idea now here which is
another mistake but it's it's not easy
to see like the only move the computer
says like keeps you alive the computer
really wanted you to go here with the
idea of attacking the rook and then
going here but it's funny he went here
because he wanted to go there in one
move yeah you guy get there in like 3 a4
movies you know that and I'm gonna check
you along the way that's another move
you got a waste and now what's funny is
he used all of his pieces which is wrong
that showed him you actually do just get
a phenomenal position if you check right
away go through with the idea without
bringing I mean obviously you want
another look on the e-file it seems
seems good so we'll go over why it's a
mistake and now if you go here I guess I
can go here and I know I do lose this so
but black is you know still a little bit
better here even though I mean I like
like a lot Peters not as impressed when
the game he went here and white you know
all right just go tacked upon here and
we'll see one difference on this line
now Bishop b4 which was not played is
not as good because you can take this
and if you're you take this
and okay and you can go here and it's
sort of funny that the knight is
protecting this bond it's kind of funny
so he played the better move now sort of
a surprising move he went here tacking
to work but this is wrong
he took we won't go over go go let's see
let's see if the main line is actually
interesting he should just play here 93
he took but now black wins some material
okay so he takes upon check all right
looks kind of dangerous g5 exactly so
after he won here I mean blacks up a lot
of pawns see so it didn't last much
longer here and then he resigned on his
move
I guess he assumed to the work would
move I assume he takes on d5 so down a
thousand pawns he decide to throw in the
towel so again you know another example
of how theoretical this opening can get
but I hope that doesn't really deter
people from playing it this does do it
for the Benoni
you know until next week when I have
part four we got more stuff to cover ah
yeah so yeah until next week I hope you
guys you know hit like share subscribe
tell all your friends put it on the
internet Facebook YouTube however you
however it works out on the how it works
you
you